welcome to this video pom burito is the
opponent let's see from
Argentina never played this guy right
no I'm still amazed how often you get
opponents that you never have played
before player pool is really big
here okay the
arck it's playing with early early C6
H there are those F4 ideas is this one
of those positions okay let's let's try
that I I never
really um yeah studied studied those F4
ideas I know that you can play F4 even
after Knight A6
immediately ah interesting what is his
idea with that move
H I don't
know let's just wow well this looks ugly
yeah
F6 what's the what's the idea
yeah want to play E5 or I really don't I
really don't get
that it looks like black has misplaced
all his
pieces okay um let's see how do I play
now
interesting yeah well T King is sort of
helping him
right he might take on F4
I can take here play
D5 take
here but D takes D takes E5 looks
strategically really
wrong but the problem is if he takes
here I'm sort of in a double
attack okay maybe here to be able to
recapture with the bishop I mean as ugly
as it looks it's not totally clear how
to
exploited okay I will
recapture I probably have to play King
H1 at some point get out of this
sensitive B6 or A7 G1
diagonal yes
but H yeah okay I have to do this at
some
point let's see okay he's dropping back
but if I go B4 now and Knight E6 isn't
this winning this winning the exchange
right I mean there has to be some draw
back to this to this to
this swiss cheese formation here with
all those
weaknesses okay so um C5 or take the
exchange I just take the exchange he
also cannot take on
B4 okay do I just play A3 or B5 five
yeah just A3 keep all the
squares black is sitting in a totally
passive position I I mean I don't need
to um give him any squares like B5
Knight
C5 okay how to continue probably
probably F5 at some
point
um yeah he wants to play A5 I
guess okay let's open up the whole thing
I want to win this with a kingside
attack he has uh no defensive pieces
anyway C5 and Bishop C4
check
Che
yeah Bishop E5 M or something like that
would be really
cute um if I take f8 and play Queen d8
isn't this like a total total disaster
check yeah I think it is and queen
d8 queen d8 attacking the queen and
attacking E5 with
mate it's a little bit of a showof thing
here but isn't this
winning yeah I see I don't see a defense
here I'm just I mean Knight A6 I will
take Bishop E5 mate there is there is no
defense to that and the queen is
hanging black resigns yeah that wasn't
nice finish but uh I mean yeah you you
cannot play like that with with with
I really think this is this is not not
in any way justifiable yeah he's got
misplaced pieces all around and and it's
full of weaknesses so I don't really
think that this is a playable playable
setup okay took here here yeah H the
comp actually already wants to play Rook
B1 with a win threatening
B4 yeah I played this routine move which
is probably second rate in
comparison but okay he he went right
into this
um loss of material
anyway and now E5 is uh is opening up
the position um decisively C5 the check
check check and here Queen G5 is also
winning but this is this is just too
neat not to
play he has no way to avoid the M
something a mate like that check mate
will will finish the game yeah okay this
was nice thanks for watching